i'm also
um a very talented rapper and that is
i do freestyle right that's right that's
made up it's uh it's improvised it's not
written it's not prepared it's not
rehearsed one person is very excited for
that
everyone else is like oh can we leave
now can we really love you that's right
thank you
i
i want to know what you guys want to
hear a wrap about but don't what did you
say depression yes yes as in the the
mental the mental health problem not the
period in the 1950s
and so when it comes to depression and
let's dive into that uh do you you said
you suffer from depression 100 100 wait
all the time
all the time you're masking it very well
i want
so we have queen elizabeth depression
you're shouting megan markle yeah okay
i'm very much team megan whatever
yeah meghan markle um or if you call her
roman initials thousand thousand
so okay queen elizabeth's depression did
you say the day no because will spoke
about in the day i like that okay so
okay let's see we've got the queen's
depression
okay
guys
this is so raucous and unruly
we're coming to this side
what's up sorry you said carnival and
you said the gays
[Applause]
okay erectile dysfunction
the gays
the queen's depression today and then
what are you showing over here
putin's benjamin
[Applause]
has there been a news story about this
recently that i didn't hear about
is that to me because i remember i
remember there was all that talk of like
trump
and then you guys know that like biden
he's on his way during sex but that's
just because incontinence is really
common
he doesn't need to
so the queen's depression the days
the gays oh that's going to be good in
it
function in putin's bedroom this then is
a free stuff that's the right method
from the spot based entirely on
suggestions it's not written it's not
prepared it's not rehearsed and if you
can drop that because sir it will not be
as bad as you're expecting it to be so
let's uh let's play that let's have some
fun
[Applause]
oh i chose such a good beat that's great
let's uh have fun i love the little hand
signals you were doing cool
action with the hands like a sign it's a
protel and slap the hands moving your
two guys italian we're having fun here
parade hand movements like a limp wrist
[Music]
[Applause]
even if i wanted to flow on the ocean
yeah once i went out to the storm wall
bar i walked in looking to find myself a
new papaya i found a dab a bunny he was
playing in the drinks i referenced the
game he said what do you think i'm like
why are you really offended he's like
please don't kind of insert in it the
t-h-e i don't respect you all you can
say gays you can say homosexual but if
you got the definite article in front
it's kind of
the word just grabs your erectile
dysfunction you need the viagra
take a little hill if you're over the
hill you need to get a prescription
[Music]
they send it through your mailbox if you
were chosen to get that treatment no
prescription i wanna get a clean [ __ ]
so the position that i adopt is a nice
little squat i've got a day going cold
and hot
better
[Music]
if
she says they want my jewels
wait how old are you 96 97 maybe 98. in
a month it will prove to be a big
celebration it's a jubilee i love that
you be clapping i'm rapping about
platinum as the plan of jubilee is
what's gonna happen
to rescue any prostitutes that he's
taken there at gunpoint i know cohen's
done this at some point he was always
excited and filled with glee he wanted
to get his rocks off in the kgb he's
like oh yes i select you come on lady to
my bedroom
white lennon's two like he sees stalin
putin assumes that no one knows what's
going on where his friends be but that
position in his better envy is about to
come but then he gets ended see why he's
assassinated from behind by celeste
[Applause]